[Music]
while many films from the 90s hold up to
this day
others are sadly so of their time that
there's little reason to revisit them
save for a quick dose of nostalgia from
sci-fi to prestige dramas
here are some 90s films that haven't
aged well
released at the very onset of early
internet culture ian softly's hackers
isn't just an ode to the oregon trail
generation
it's a bright shiny encapsulation of mid
90s computer technology
in all its role of lading glory planet
shut up
the film centers on a group of teen
hackers in new york
led by dade zero call slash crash
override murphy and kate acid burn libby
along with their friends a serial killer
lord nikon and the phantom freak
dade and kate unite a worldwide network
of hackers to take down ellingson
mineral company
computer security officer eugene the
plague belford
and secret service agent richard gill
hackers worked in 1995 if for no other
reason and the fact that the internet
was still such a new commodity
many households had little to no
interaction with the world wide web
outside of a few aol emails and the idea
that the internet
actually looked like something in this
case a mix of virtual cityscape
and those old magic eye posters was
totally believable because people had no
idea that it didn't actually look like
anything
add to that a group of high schoolers
who exemplified the very height of 90s
rave fashion and you've got a film
that's pretty impossible to watch
outside of nostalgia's sake like hackers
in 1995's the net was a reflection of a
time when it was clear that hollywood
had no idea what the internet was
actually like
unlike hackers however the net took a
far less optimistic approach to
computers
in this film systems analyst angela
burnett stumbles upon a cyber conspiracy
that revolves around the use of a
computer security system called
gatekeeper once involved angela becomes
a target of greg microsystems the
software company that owns and operates
gatekeeper
her identity is a race replaced with
that of a woman wanted by the fbi for
among other things prostitution it's a
movie that spends two hours trying to
make a piece of malware look like it can
take down the entire us government
the net also buys into the idea that
people who work with computers
are unable to also have social lives the
biggest problem for angela once she
loses her identity is that she can't
convince anyone of who she is
because she doesn't actually talk to
anyone in the real world her entire life
exists online
from any source of meaningful social
interaction to ordering pizza
in 1995 that was a potential death
sentence
today it's twitter and grubhub the early
90s wasn't kind to video game
adaptations
super mario brothers failed to impress
and star bob hoskins famously called the
film quote
the worst thing i ever did the following
year both double dragon and street
fighter fared even worse
with one critic calling the former a
quote low iq futuristic slugfest
while the latter was marked by his
inability to live up to its source
material
as for mortal kombat which hit theaters
in august 1995
it stuck pretty close to the original
game's narrative three earth realm
fighters liu kang
johnny cage and sonia blade are
recruited by god of thunder raiden to
fight against shang tsung and the
invading forces of outworld in an
interdimensional tournament
it's a simple plot but it was a simple
game and at the time of its release it
all sort of worked
looking at it now though through the
lens of over 25 years of technological
advancements and
arguably improvements in scripting
mortal kombat is a complete cheese fest
that's difficult to sit through without
laughing the dialogue comes across like
parody with shang tsung's over-the-top
villainous one-liners of particular
notes
[Music]
but the worst offense here is the
effects which were by 1995 standards
passable
today though let's just forget about
scorpion's palm spear
the 1997 rom-com chasing amy tells the
story of holden mcneil
a comic book artist who falls in love
with fellow artist alyssa jones
there is however one difficult obstacle
in the way of holden's pursuit of her
alyssa is a lesbian ultimately the pair
do embark on a romantic relationship but
it's played with issues
specifically holden's insecurity to
finding out he isn't the first man
alyssa has been with upon its release
the film was lauded for its progressive
approach to sexuality and relationships
and it turned kevin smith an independent
spirit award for his screenplay
but chasing amy isn't without its flaws
the film has come under fire for
perpetuating an idea that a woman who
identifies as a lesbian
just needs to find the right man in
order to go straight and that if a guy
tries hard enough he can convince any
woman to fall in love with him
regardless of her sexual preference in
an interview with buzzfeed news
gonna grenavia turner the real-life
inspiration for alyssa's character
noted that she understands the aversion
newer audiences might have toward the
film
however she defends it for being one of
the first to portray a lesbian character
with a quote
complicated sexuality for anyone
entering into adulthood in the mid-90s
reality bites was pretty much considered
required viewing
centering on the post-college lives of
four friends lalena
troy vicky and sammy who lived together
in houston
the film was a perfect encapsulation of
the era and the disenfranchised youth
that made up generation x
in 1994 having no direction in life and
a competitive type attitude towards your
friends was kind of attractive
so long as you could write terrible
coffeehouse poetry and talk for hours
about important social
and moral issues or chain smoking a pack
of marlboro reds
today you'd probably get dropped from
your friend group we're specifically
talking about troy here because looking
at reality bites through a modern lens
makes one thing perfectly painfully
clear troy was the absolute worst
the 90s were shockingly forgiving of
some pretty unforgiving behaviors
especially when it came from a guy in a
loose button down with unkempt hair
and a crooked smile troy was
narcissistic emotionally manipulative
and just kind of mean
i am really in love with you
is that what you want to hear is it
while guys like troy continue to exist
in cinema today
they genuinely don't get the girl in the
end because the girl has had enough
of troy's garbage four years before
keanu reeves took on the role of neo in
the matrix trilogy
he played johnny the mnemonic courier
turned into netero
in robert longo's cyberpunk sci-fi
thriller johnny mnemonic
in longo's film information is currency
people like johnny have data storage
devices implanted into their brains for
the express purpose
of transferring sensitive information
across the net for various corporations
and organized crime circuits
when johnny's latest package happens to
contain the cure for a neurological
disease caused by using the internet
he's forced into a fight not only with
the head of a pharmacological company
that wants it for himself but also with
the yakuza
as entertaining as johnny mnemonic is
and watching reeves johnny team up with
ice-t and a cybernetic dolphin is
endlessly entertaining
it's hard to ignore just how bad the
film's depiction of future tech is
in order to access his brain's hard
drive johnny enters into a vr world
through the use of a giant visor
a pair of gloves that look like
high-tech protective padding and a fax
machine
because in 2021 the best and fastest way
to transmit information
still involves dial up longo probably
meant for johnny mnemonic to be some
kind of statement on society's
inevitable enslavement to technology but
it's hard to buy into that when vcrs
play a huge role in that vision
american beauty is something of an
anomaly here in that it took home
five academy awards sweeping most of the
major categories
at the heart of the film is lester
burnham a middle-aged magazine exec
whose life is anything but fulfilling
when it all starts to unravel
lester embarks on a path of
self-discovery and improvement one that
also happens to include actively
pursuing his teenage daughter's best
friend
angela as cringe-worthy as that
particular storyline may be on its own
what makes this one especially awful to
watch is a shadow of spacey's personal
life that looms so heavily over it
and subsequently over every other role
he's had on screen
following a series of sexual assault
allegations from over 30 victims
spacey's career has been tainted and
trying to sit through an on-screen
flirtation between him and a young woman
is anything but entertaining nestled
into the summer of 1999 was a film that
would go on to define an entire
generation
and one that would have a slew of
sequels and spin-offs american pie
the raunchy teen comedy made waves with
its graphic depiction of coming of age
hilarity
and it also launched the careers of a
number of actors some went on to have
continued success
while others not so much american pie
has no shortage of vulgar jokes and
tasteless scenes but there's one in
particular that makes it completely
unwatchable today
when jim's friends convince him to set
up a webcam in his room so they can
watch foreign exchange students nadia
and dress the act is treated like any
other joke in the film
god bless the internet it's one that
supposedly gets funnier once jim decides
to join in
nowadays the same sort of joke would be
punishable by a hefty fine and
jail time filming someone without their
consent isn't funny the fact that nadia
winds up losing her sponsorship over it
thereby being the one punished is even
worse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]